[Music]
so this is party bus United so
previously we always had note bots at
JavaScript conference but in all this
what we did was the right-hand side
which were like simple BOTS cars that we
you would we would give the participants
and they would work on it and make it
stylistic so this times we wanted to be
more adventurous and try something new
so in the first session what we did was
we met made that so everybody get a
clear idea on how to control robots
using nodejs then what we wanted to do
was for them to make a bot that you
would use in a party it can be vaguely
at a party but then it's okay so we
brought a lot of stuff for them we had
poppers we were hoping to use some
flames or five lugs also but then we
didn't thank God I guess so those are
the things so I'll present to that two
that are here so this is one of the bots
one of the participants made its a
clapper so there is a motor running that
raises the wood thing and then it just
drops the next one is something like a
windmill so there's a fan so the idea is
when you turn up the turn on the lights
at home or the party is finished and
everybody turns of the lights then the
fan try gets blowing so that's the idea
behind it so then we'll go into the
other demos so if you can go to the live
demo live view so yeah so this would do
it first and the second
so this is supposed to be a cocktail or
a drink maker kind of thing so the idea
is let's see first okay so the idea is
this is supposed to work wireless in the
future or it's supposed to be working
Wireless so the idea is when somebody is
pouring the water here for the water
there so if there is a cup it if it pour
the water there in if you do it really
good it could be something like a magic
trick so that's our first pot that we
made so the second one so the second one
is supposed to be something like so it's
another variation of a fan okay
yeah so you it actually blows very good
vend that's all right so let's now take
a look at the the other four who's gonna
talk about it
so first up please introduce yourself
for yourselves so my name is James and
this is Leon what did you set out to do
and is that the same thing is what it
became
roughly is so we started in the morning
with a car and then we decided that this
what looks like a toilet seat is
actually a basketball hoop so the
concept is like an arcade game where you
have a basketball hoop and you shoot it
in except one person can control it so
it makes it difficult for the other
person to score yeah passive aggressive
basketball hoop yes that's it
[Laughter]
except so oh it is my name is having us
and I have created a bot that that uses
mobilizer controller and besides it to
be can you the wise command like front
back left or right and it will do its
job accordingly so and this is working
yeah Wow
yeah so if I am giving the front
[Music]
it will go left it will go right if I
will speak front walk back left right
[Applause]
for this I have used the emesis web RTC
SDK and I am recognizing the Y's and
after that I am sending that to the SDK
of RTC channel and after that it is
sending the signal to the robot and it
is doing its job accordingly that's
impressive to the design change while
you were producing it did you objective
change the intention change while you
were building it or was this more or
less what you set out to produce mmm
actually we can do little bit more thing
like machine learning on device
recognition so we can call either Google
library Google API dot AI or Watson or
we can use Alexa library and rest of the
things commands will be changed same the
similar thing can be used for mind
controlling we can train this for
controlling by mind so if somebody is
thinking far left it will go left it
will overwrite but for that I know one
emitter okay so let's start with who are
you oh hi I'm Melvin and this is San our
third member of the team is well yeah
he's somewhere out there having lunch
and a party but is going to dance and
any of a surprise what could possibly go
wrong
okay yeah so hi this is Terry and this
is my partner mathé we have another one
para I couldn't find him so this is what
we this is the LED stripe and see what's
on it can alright okay what if I spin it
it's going up
intermittently okay the idea is you're
supposed to see something this doesn't
seem like a robot how is this a robot
it's this is a robot who can have this
one-dimensional thing as a
two-dimensional degree display had you
intended that the Rebbe will have its
own arm to do this with it's actually
it's harder to use a human's beam
because you don't have like a steady rpm
that's the idea
so okay very cool okay how do we do on
the it's that called tech support
Lavallee
[Laughter]
all right
do you have other go this one or is this
[Laughter]
no are we giving up or is it all right
this might be an appropriate moment okay
we're not seeing it sort of text okay
version two okay so this is me
attempting to pronounce names this time
because my co-host has already gotten
his turn so I'm just repeating the names
for those who have been who's had their
lightning talks being selected so first
up is yuzu schwa the second person is
and um I've met the third person is from
param Sandra I'm sorry I'm really sorry
if I met any of your names the fourth
person is shilling Thai the fifth person
is you're sure you use person is rjl
elbow yeah that's that's it so if your
name has been caught you really should
show up at the through that is 2:45 time
slot where you'll be you'll be have a
chance to actually talk about your
lightning talks
great great thank you
hopefully all six people have heard at
least one of those announcements so
apparently this final partybot
having now built up the expectation is
going to dance for us
[Laughter]
this needs some music I if I sing
everybody will leave okay the most
exciting part of the dance hasn't yet
happened and I think all the electronics
just fell apart that's cheating
[Laughter]
but also effective yes okay anything
else we have a few minutes we'd like to
talk about things that didn't didn't
work yeah so one of the ideas was so one
of the ideas we had was to do there was
a sound controlled
so a sound control audio equalizer kind
of thing but with with actual like LED
no strips and one one thing we found out
was the the port or the sensor that we
were using was not not that powerful
enough or the quality was not that good
so we weren't able to do it one of the
other things we tried was like a nerf
gun that you can shoot one of the the
problem there was there was a thing in
the nerf grande one in in the nerf gun
that we had you have to charge it or do
some action beforehand and that was it
it was not only a trigger so that was a
hard thing too
so you need a sort of IOT optimized nerf
gun yes so those were those are the
things we tried well we did try we I
think we lost many boards on our Dino
nanos and who knows trying to make these
things and yeah it's hard yes I think
that's pretty much all that we try
did try alright well it's fantastic
I think huge round of applause for
actually making hardware work that's
always tough
[Applause]